I just hit 20 years of my sister being
dead my sister I didn't know about that
I know about your dad yeah my dad which
is you know there's like jokes on on the
special about it but my sister my dad
died in 97 and then my sister died two
years later and then my sister died
October 29th of 99 and uh it was a
Halloween party I found out because she
died the 29th and then on the 30th I
went with my friend to his sister's
house party in Boulder at University of
Colorado because I grew up in Denver I
grew up in Aurora and we um we went up
to the University of Colorado and it's
so funny to watch people be like in
masks and stuff like It's a Spooky Night
you're like no no no no [__] you guys I
just I just my sister just got crushed
on items yeah yeah you want to hear
something scary my [__] sister got
hit from behind on I-10 and [__]
killed